i live on svalbard which is an island
close to the north pole and right now we
have the polar night which means that we
have zero daylight at all so this is at
3 pm on a regular day
oh yeah and the northern lights showed
up so we were walking under that
beautiful and yeah this could be potable
tracks so that's exciting
when walking your dog is an expedition
this is my fur child grim it's starting
to get really cold here and it's pitched
like 24 7. so you start with thermos
then expedition pants then down sausage
jacket and then your teletubby headlight
and of course that's not enough we have
polar bears here so we have to bring a
rifle with us every time we're outside
so this is my rifle
the dogs are obviously invisible in the
dark so i put a bunch of blinkies and
high vis vests on them so i can actually
see them when they run away from me
this was the beautiful weather this is
in the middle of the day
so zero daylight that's where i live
and we live in our cabin 15 minutes
outside longer viewing so it's not very
far we don't have any running water but
we do have electricity and it's very
very cozy that buff life though so i
race the guys from this point every time
we go on a walk and you would expect
them to get to the cabin quicker than me
but they make a lot of these kind of
stops so we end up coming to the cabin
at the same time today i thought i would
show you longer bin and our main street
here we have some of our stores this is
the main street at 2pm on a regular day
on the street we have the bank the post
office the supermarket and stores
and
what else do we have a bunch of stuff
really restaurants cafes and in here is
our shopping center so this is really
the only shopping center there are other
stores but this is like the only place
that's inside so you can buy jewelry and
regular clothes expedition gear this is
women's square i also work in there we
also have our only pharmacy in here and
of course we have some beautiful polar
bear art because we love polar bears
this is one of our two cafes called
frivona and
they are
selling a bunch of good stuff and cool
stuff what am i saying i don't know but
yeah so they have knitting
evenings on thursdays is this what you
thought today i'm gonna tell you a
little bit about my story
when i moved to svalbard i was supposed
to stay here for three months now five
years later i'm still here and i live in
a cabin that me and my boyfriend own and
i'm living the most amazing life life up
here in the arctic is just focused on
nature it's very peaceful and
stress-free we spend most of our time
outside going on snowmobile trips or
hiking or just watching the beautiful
northern lights
even though we are cut off from the
world in one way we live in this amazing
bubble where we just enjoy the nature
and the incredible scenery that's around
us
every season has its beauty whether it's
the snow-covered mountains in the winter
or the northern lights in the polar
night or just the glacier cabin in the
summer
it's all just beautiful
svalbard really is a very magical place